do you guys uh as celebrities do you
guys have special drug dealers that like
only deal with celebrities or is it just
kind of like
you have to be cautious of that when
you're buying drugs after like a movie
yeah me personally i never
i don't feel like i ever got lucky to
where i found like something where you i
get what you're saying where you get
like a dude delivering that like we'll
specialize and be quiet i feel like i
again when i especially here in l.a like
you go to skid row and [ __ ] yeah like
straight up to down like i had a guy
that i could call but he didn't even
know who i was i remember at one point
being really really like i had no money
and i was really dope sick and i
remember bringing like a poster of one
of my movies signed and like
and like a few like a few like items
that i had and and like i had like a um
uh stereo surround sound
and i brought it all to him i'm like
come on man i have no money i'm sorry he
said come on man come on and i'm like
look at this poster man this is at least
40 bucks right here so he's like i don't
care like he didn't want anything i
brought him but the stereo surround
sound but he still was annoyed about
that so that was my one guy for years
that i dealt with
um but yeah i never had
that like you know
and then coke would for me coke was
always if you go out people would offer
me coke no one ever offered me heroin or
opiates it was a taboo like no one ever
offered that i had to like find someone
and like maybe someone sold a couple
pills or i'd go get heroin would be
downtown and it was the same guy for a
long time
um but yeah not me and not me i don't
know about it the way scott asked that
question i think he was
framing it a little bit more like
uh
you know people who aren't gonna say hey
i'd sold drugs to jason muse you know
but i think that when you're in the
space of drug dealing like i think that
a little bit of uh discretion kind of
comes along with the turf anyway yeah
you're not putting that on your linkedin
you know like dude it's crazy to me to
imagine like i think that's gotta be my
biggest fear in the [ __ ] whole world
is to be like famous and broke to be
like recognizable and and and like not
have money and like and have a drug
habit like [ __ ] dude that no it was yeah
it's it was uh i mean again for me again
i don't
again i feel like i'm at to i don't feel
like i'm uh up there up there but it it
would for me yes it would be like it's
things that
to have
to at one point would have money and
then i wouldn't have money like i'd make
a movie and let's say i had a whole
bunch of money and then by the time i
started buying drugs especially the this
one the one round like i remember i was
because i didn't want to in my head i
thought if i don't get heroin
i'm going to be all right if i'm only
doing vicodin vicodin sort of tame you
know it's not even oxycontin it's
vicodin but because i had a habit i was
no lie doing minimum 20 like right yes
isn't that bad for your stomach oh so i
would taste it through my liver
sometimes up to 60 a day but that would
add up man that's like even 20 20 is at
least 100 bucks so minimum i'm spending
100 to 200 bucks a day some days i'd
spend 400 bucks a day so you got to
think you know that's what let's say
that's 700 bucks a week
times four is what a month i mean and
that's minimum you know so for like
three months i spent like you know 20
grand on bikini
so so then i'll send you like oh my gosh
i almost have like no money left over
because i'm like not spending it wise
and anyway so i agree and it's such a
weird thing where people are like hey
you want to come out like
it's it's it's yeah but i could see that
especially for me now even more so
because i feel like i have a family and
all that stuff and and i can't even
imagine my wife still again every once
in a while will she have like a bad
dream and she'll be like i had a bad
dream you were using i'm like you don't
there's no way i would use right now and
again i know it's always possible you
shouldn't say never ever but i can't
imagine it especially with my kid and
like you know and luckily like even with
i let her control all the money and
stuff like if i go where all the stuff
the checks go to her if i if i go like i
don't even want to know like so like you
want to know how much you made this week
i'm like i don't care i'm like i just
wanna like i really don't like um i just
want her to hold it all and i don't
wanna
even know because it's just like she's
the she's
handles everything better anyway so um
that's good man
i feel like we're
like we're
we've cut we've covered on the the the
the addiction yes yeah i think we've got
we're like we're good let's not beat you
up with that [ __ ] is this to the time
time or is it that is the time okay cool
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude